Kate Walsh reveals she had a brain tumor
it was like a small lemon the former
Grey's Anatomy star stopped by the Today
Show on Monday and opened up about being
diagnosed with a brain tumor two years
ago when I was working out Maya plot his
instructors like oh your right side is
dipping and I'm like that doesn't feel
like it's off and then I was driving and
I would start sort of swerving into the
right lane exhausted I could drink
several cups of coffee does not have any
energy then she began noticing cognitive
changes I couldn't find my words wasn't
finishing sentences and thoughts and it
sort of it was subtle and then it got
pretty pretty apparent pretty quick the
actress decided to see a neurologist and
got an MRI that showed she had a sizable
brain tumor in her left frontal lobe
three days later the 49 year olds headed
into surgery to have it removed and
learnt the growth was benign Kate took
nine months off before going back to
work
starring in girls trip and thirteen
reasons why now she's partnering with
Cigna to raise awareness and focusing on
what's really important if I come out of
this all right I I want to spend more
time with my family and friends I want
to work on projects that I just love
with people that I love
I want to travel be of service you know
do just all the kind of things that you
hear but it's yeah for real
[Music]